and of course the biggest question of
all is why is autism on the rise the
latest CDC statistics from the United
States indicate that one in 88 children
will eventually receive an ASD diagnosis
by all indications the statistics are
very similar in Canada as discussing
this article in nature in 2011 entitled
the prevalence puzzle autism counts the
left graft documents the increase in the
number of diagnosis between 1975 and
2009 the right pie graph provides
possible explanations which include the
following first spatial clustering which
may account for up to four percent of
the increase in this group it is
surmised that there could be an
environmental agent affecting
populations or perhaps for one reason or
another a neighborhood of families could
become so sophisticated on the topic of
autism that a cluster of informed
parents and specialists builds up
diagnosing and treating more children
the second reason which may account for
up to ten percent of the increase may be
explained by a social change with
biological implications for example
people now tend to have children older
in life because of Education and the
social structure set up by a
knowledge-based a capacity and there's
data emerging from both population and
genetic studies that indicate children
born to parents older than 35 have a
higher risk of being diagnosed with
autism third 15% of the observed
increase may be accounted for by growing
awareness about autism simply put more
parents and pediatricians know about it
so it is diagnosed more often fourth
perhaps another twenty-five percent of
the rise in autism may be attributed to
the so-called diagnostic accretion that
as children who would have been
diagnosed with what we used to call
mental retardation or now intellectual
disability a decade ago Arnel get now
given a diagnosis of both intellectual
disability and autism or just autism
alone this nature article suggests in
his groupings suggested groupings would
leave forty six percent of the increase
in autism as unexplained in my opinion
the environment will most certainly have
a role in this unexplained category when
scientists think about environment they
tend to think of the word
environment is having a capital e which
I equate to involving environmental
pollutants and toxins or the word
environment may actually begin with a
small e which could equate to social
behavioral changes including all the
already mentioned issues of spatial
clustering parental age awareness and
diagnostic accretion plus other
explanations other contributing small e
environmental influences could be
societal changes arising due to
differences in the workplace introduced
by the Information Age new
anthropological factors may also have a
play with respect to how mates find each
other what we call a sorted of mating or
even what forces are shaping the brains
and therefore human evolution returning
back to the capital leaf form of
environment the challenge has always
been as I alluded to earlier that it's
very very very complex in fact so
complex it's probably impossible to to
tackle in a non hypothesis directed
manner however there is much evidence in
the field that new genes and the animal
models and cell models that I talked
about can now provide bona fide targets
for systematic testing of potential
environmental toxins for their effects
in autism so I would just summarize my
talk on this last slide by boring from
some of the themes presented earlier the
clinical Trailblazers like like
professor can or an asperger and wing
and rudder and others some on this
audience have developed the concept of
the triad of behavioral symptoms namely
impairments in the reciprocal social
interaction verbal and nonverbal
communication and preference for
repetitive stereotypical interests and
behaviors to help us define what we now
call autism spectrum disorder this
behavioral classification will always be
the mainstay of autism diagnosis the
past decade or so however has brought to
mend it tremendous advances in first
studies of genetics of autism and second
understanding the role of the brain in
autism specific specific genes such as
the ones that i have discussed have now
been identified and it is now known that
the protein products that they encode
are involved in development and
maintenance of neuronal synapses in some
cases when there is a deserve
in the balance of these proteins at the
synapse sometimes too much sometimes too
little the brain cells work differently
which can lead to autism importantly I
think going forward to attempt to fully
understand the enigma we call autism we
need to consider a new triad a new
paradigm that encompasses the three core
concepts shown in the modified Venn
diagram on this slide the three core
concepts include the clinical
understanding in blue the genomic
understanding in red and understanding
of the brain in green as is often the
case when studying such complex systems
in science i believe the next round of
breakthroughs will come by studying the
medical and scientific data sets
operating at and being derived from the
interface of these different systems
ultimately with this knowledge we will
understand the individual in a more
complete way and this will drive forward
new breakthroughs offering hope for
better treatment options and individuals
with and families with autism last is
important to re-emphasize that every
complex biological system is really a
sensor of its environments studying the
environmental influences on the
individual at each stage of life may not
only provide explanations for the
unexplained causes of autism but also
provide a different path forward in
prevention and treatment this last image
shown at the center of the graph is of
course Tom Thompson's famous painting
called the west wind here a solitary
pine tree stands reminiscent of the
neurons and autism perhaps this tree has
a sparser branching network compared to
other trees this may be due to the
nature of the genetics of the individual
tree or because it stands away from the
protective forest weathering the rather
harsh Canadian climate like it is today
as we attempt to continue to decipher
the complexities of autism we will need
to study the trees in exquisite detail
but also the forests surrounding them
thank you very your attention
so Steve thank you very very much I
think you get a sense of what we were
saying in that we were actually at the
verge of understanding and moving things
along and yet there's still tremendous
complexity that exists and we're going
to pursued some of this a little bit
further with our panel discussion i'm
going to introduce our other two
panelists and then i'm going to ask each
of them to come up and give us say
something for about a few minutes five
minutes and then we're going to have a
general questions that i'm going to
introduce we will not have an open
audience question and answer but we will
have time later on to ask them at the
coffee in cookies I think we're going to
have after so if we don't have cookies
I'm going to be disappointed